school walkouts were only the beginning
this weekend thousands of anti-gun
protesters are descending on Washington
DC they'll be demanding that government
restrict our right to bear arms what
they probably won't be marching for is
better law enforcement maybe they should
because Nicholas Cruz was only able to
carry out that massacre because both
police ignored warnings about to his
behavior and then cowered in fear during
the shooting itself
meanwhile at Great Mills High School in
Maryland today a potential mass shooting
was halted when an armed school resource
officer confronted a gunman who had shot
two students only the gunman was killed
he's the Nicholas is the University of
Maryland and he joins us tonight
professor thanks for coming on thank you
so look I understand people have
different opinions about the Second
Amendment how far its protections extend
what gun control laws work or what don't
but you can't look at the massacre that
will be commemorated this weekend and
come away not concluding if you're
honest that the problem was the laws in
place were not enforced that someone who
was clearly a threat and known to be a
threat was ignored was allowed to buy a
gun and that the police on the scene
four of them did nothing to stop the
massacre
that's all factual and it's being
ignored in favor of attack of the NRA
why is that so I think there are a
couple of things number one I'll tell
you just personally I'm Pro responsible
gun ownership and pro-gun control and I
think one of the things that's a problem
is we frame this argument as if you know
those two things can't coexist I think
as far as Nicholas Cruz I think that
some of the things you were saying are
correct but when we talk about the great
mills situation it's someone who by all
accounts was a good kid had no problems
respectful and honor student but had
access to a gun that's it and that's
because the big prayer of course
millions of students who meet that
description of access to guns who don't
hurt anybody in the case of Nicholas no
said millions of young children when
they have access in that there are
millions of American homes where people
safely keep firearms lots of
I mean kids hunt actually in rural
America lots of them and in some places
they bring their rifles to school during
deer season they don't hurt anybody
that's been going on for generations
okay that's the truth of it so the point
is here you have someone with
demonstrable mental illness who should
not legally have been allowed to buy a
gun but was because the authorities
ignored it so if you really care about
stopping school shootings why are we
ignoring that I don't know I'm really
honestly confused I understand what
you're saying I also believe that one of
the issues is the fact that he was I
believe 19 years old and was able to buy
a pistol now I think that that's a
problem okay because you're me but again
he wasn't legally allowed to buy any gun
because he was mentally ill and known to
be mentally ill he was the subject of
scores of policemen disagree this is an
actual massacre in which 17 people died
absolutely nobody on the left is saying
word one about it they're in effect
protecting the people who failed by not
calling it out on their failures in
favor of making statements about the NRA
which was not involved in any way in
this massacre so I'm watching the good
faith I think what they're trying to do
is cover all bases I've heard people say
that there was wrong on the part of law
enforcement that people should have
picked this up earlier with Nicholas
Cruz but like I said with with Young
Rollins today he was not somebody that
the FBI or law enforcement could have
picked up we don't know that actually we
didn't know what screws because failure
just happens I'm I'm just saying this
guy killed 70 people so looking here
very quickly this is the question I want
to ask the organizers of the March but
they're so cowardly to come on and
explain but it's a simple question
what specific law are we calling for
here I think that there are many things
that they're calling for they're calling
for an end to bump stocks they're
calling for a raise in the age limit we
we have a kid who was 18 or 19 for a
name to bump stock so there haven't
finished I haven't finished
we have kids that we say are not mature
enough or emotionally intelligent enough
to take a drink of alcohol but we're
willing to give
I'm a deadly weapon kid let me ask you
know do you really believe that affordab
and bum star ban bump stocks and the
president thinks doing it unilaterally
anyway
and raise the age for firing purchases
to 21 sure you think we didn't school
shootings I think we would limit some of
those school shootings you do think that
I do well I think you know when we look
at Nikolas Cruz leave who's already not
allowed to buy a gun but the authorities
because they didn't want to add to the
the sum total were 21 he probably would
not have been able to get into that
school I think that there that he wasn't
allowed to buy a gun in the first place
under existing law but the people in
charge didn't feel like enforcing it
again um we're not disagree so he
wouldn't have stopped that because that
would already would have been stopped
about that we should get rid of well
since she wanted to bring up bump stocks
you get rid of bump stocks a lot of
people in Las Vegas since you know we're
talking about gun violence generally a
lot of people would have still been
alive and maybe that could have had a
different bump stock makes it almost
impossible to hit anything and I'm not
sure that we know what percentage people
were killed he didn't exclusively fire
with the bump stock and anyone knows any
more guns it's a ridiculous device that
makes the gun impossible to control I'm
just saying no he wasn't sniping people
he was going and shooting and math and
just a large I'm just we're we're not
really addressing the real issues here
we're talking about you know what I mean
I think that there there are some issues
that you are correct that we need to do
a better job of enforcement but we also
look at gun violence generally we can
look at somewhere like Alaska for
example which has the highest rate of
gun violence gun deaths per capita and
you don't need a permit to buy weapons
it's it's not it's your stats are
totally wrong its suicide that's
Alaska's problem
that's a massive issue as well not
nothing to do with guns anyway in
Louisiana Mississippi but okay to see
professor they absolutely always fought